اهلا بكم من جديد تسيطر حاله من القلق على
الاسواق العالميه كما ترتفع حاله العزوف
عن المخاطره على الرغم من الاجراءات
الصارمه التي اتخذتها السلطات الحكوميه
الامريكيه بالاضافه الى تعهد الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي والبنك المركزي الاوروبي وبنوك
مركزيه كبرى في العالم بتعزيز السيوله في
السوق ودعم المصارف جاءت هذه التطورات
عاقبا انهيار البنوك الامريكيه سلاسل
حيث يخشى المستثمرون من ازمه ماليه عالميه
جديده مثل التي حدثت عام 2008 وهو ما يضع
مدخرات المذيعين والمستثمرين في خطر
التلاشي فيما قالت رويترز ان المستثمرين
او ان المستثمرين صعدوا بحذر الى اسهم
البنوك الثلاثاء بتشجيع من نجاح عمليه
انقاذ بنك
وسط تساؤلات لمتداولين ومستثمرين عما اذا
كانت الزيادات الحاده التي اتخذها بنك
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي في اسعار الفائده قد
تسببت في احداث اكبر انهيار في القطاع
المصرفي منذ الازمه الماليه العالميه
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من لندن
الدكتور طارق رفاعي رئيس التنفيذي لمركز
كروم للدراسات الاستراتيجيه اهلا بك من
الرياضه الدكتور محمد مكنيو استاذ الماليه
والاستثمار في جامعه الامام اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من الرياض
معك دكتور محمد دكتور محمد السؤال المطروح
ببساطه كمشاهد اتابع واراقب كل هذه
التفاصيل الخاصه بالازمه ازمه البنوك
والمصارف هل احتفظ باموالي في البنوك هل
اسحبها كيف يمكن ان تنصحني فيما يخص هذا
الموضوع هل اراقب مثلا انتظر
طيب تحيه طيبه لك سيدتي وضيفك الكريم طبعا
يعني حقيقه احنا ما وصلنا لمرحله انه هناك
ازمه ماليه حتى انه احنا بنقول والله في
مرحله خطر احنا اللي يعتبر انا اعتقد انه
احنا في بدايه لاحداث يعني خليني اقول في
الداخل الامريكي وايضا في الداخل السويسري
يعني لم تخرج خارج نطاق اقتصاداتهم ولم
يكن لها تاثيرات كبيره جدا على الاقتصاد
العالمي لكن ما في شك انه هي لانها في
شريان مهم اللي هو القطاع المصرفي فانا
اعتقد انه احنا بنعرف انه القطاع المصرفي
يعني قطاع خطير واي اثار فيه يعني لابد ان
نفكر فيها اكثر من مره يمكن سرعه
الاستجابه من الحكومه الامريكيه وايضا
في سويسرا يمكن ساعده كثير انه تكون رده
الفعل العالميه افضل ويعني الكبير نقدر
نقول انهم هم في طور احتواء الازمه لكن ما
وصلنا الحقيقه لمرحله انه نقول والله لا
بد ان احنا اليوم في مرحله خطر كبيره جدا
على الاقتصاد العالمي هي كره ثلج انا
اعتقد لا زالت في بدايتها لو استمر انه
احنا شاهدنا في الايام القادمه هناك اي
انهيارات في بنوك مماثله رغم انه هناك في
فرق كبير الحقيقه بين الثلاث بنوك اللي
حصل فيها الانهيار في الولايات المتحده
وبين اللي حصل فيه الانهيار من حيث الحجم
ولا من حيث النشاط فبالتالي انا اعتقد انه
بشكل عام ما وصلنا لمرحله انه احنا بنخاف
على فلوسنا انه نسحبها او نتركها في
البنوك السؤال هذا نعتقد انه هو يحتاج الى
ايش حيصير معانا في الفتره القادمه جميل
هذا التفاؤل قد يقول البعض بانها قراءه
متفائله للاوضاع واقعيه متفائله خليني
اقول ولكن دكتور طارق كره الثلج التي تحدث
عنها الدكتور محمد ما الذي سيمنع تدحرجها
وما الذي سيمنع انسحابها بكل ما تتضمنه من
تفاصيل قادره ان تؤثر على مستقبل ازمه
ماليه في الايام القادمه خاصه
انا اتفق مع الدكتور محمد انه الازمه
بدينا نرى ملامح وطبعا ما هو الحل
بدت هذه الازمه مع رفع اسعار الفائده من
قبل البنوك المركزيه بعد انخفاض قياسي
لاسعار الفائده حول العالم للبنوك
المركزيه الرئيسيه مع بدايه رفع اسعار
الفائده بدينا نرى الملامح للاضرار
القادمه من هذه او من رفع اسعار فائده
خاصه بالوتيره سريعه اللي شفناها في
امريكا يعني اذا باخذ على كمثال واحد يعني
بنك سيليكون بالي يعني هو كان يستثمر في
اامن انواع السندات سندات الخزانه
الامريكيه ومع ذلك يعني شفنا عليها 15
مليار دولار خسارات غير محققه بسبب هذه
الاستثمارات وبالخاص بسبب رفع اسعار
الفائده مع الاستمرار في الاستثمار في هذه
السندات ومعناها ثاني انه مثل ما ذكر
الدكتور انه في بنوك اخرى اعتقد ان تواجه
نفس المشكله ولكن الى الان لم نرى الافصاح
عن هذه المشكله دكتور محمد قلت منذ قليل
بانه علينا ان لا نخاف ولكن هل علينا ان
نحذر هل علينا ان ناخذ بعض
الاستعدادات
وكيف وما هي
طبعا ما في شك مساله التحوط مطلب اساسي
دائما في حال حدوث اي مشاكل او ازمات
خليني اقول انه هذه الازمه هي امتداد
الازمات سابقه يعني احنا كنا قبل فتره ما
هي بعيده سنتين من الان جائحه كورونا بعد
كده عندنا التضخم واليوم احنا بنتكلم على
ازمه بعض المصارف في يعني اكبر اقتصاد في
العالم الولايات المتحده وايضا في يعني في
احد اكبر ثلاثين مصرف في العالم في سويسرا
وبالتالي انا اعتقد انه لابد من اخذ
التحوط في مساله الاستثمار في الوقت
الحالي بشكل كامل ليس فقط بسبب هذه الازمه
اللي نمر فيها اللي هي ازمه هذه المصارف
لكن انا بتكلم بشكل عام اليوم عندنا
الحقيقه يعني في ارتفاع كبير جدا في
الفائده وبالتالي ما هو الانسب بالنسبه
لنا هل والله هو الاستثمار في الاسواق
الاسواق المال هل هو الاستثمار في الذهب
هل هو الاستثمار في جهات اخرى فبالتالي
اليوم حقيقه في عندنا تنوع كبير من
الاستثمارات يخلق هذا التنوع ان اعتقد فيه
موجود في مجموعه من الفرص لكن يجب انه
احنا ناخذ بعين الاعتبار تحوط مهم فين فين
الازمه التي تخلق الفرصه بالنسبه لي
وبالتالي ممكن من خلالها انه انا اضع
فلوسي
دكتور طارق لما نتحدث عن ازمه تخص البنوك
الامريكيه
ونربطها بالدولار
المتحكم في النظام العالمي الاقتصادي
والذي قادر ان يتحكم كذلك في بقيه العملات
الاخرى هل هذا الربط صحيح او ان سعر الصرف
او ان قيمه الدولار لا تتعلق ولا ترتبط
بالاساس مع هذه الازمه مع ازمه المصارف في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
الدولار طبعا كل عمله الاساسيه حول العالم
لا علاقه عكسيه مع الازمات يعني عندما نرى
ازمات في الولايات المتحده يعني توقع يعني
العام انه نرى ضعف الدولار ولكن هذا العكس
لان الدولار يعتبر ملات امن فيعني وقت
المخاطر او ارتفاع المخاطر نرى المستثمر
يتجه الى الامان والامان هو في الدولار
نفسه او كذلك مولات امن يعتبر الذهب
ولكن تعتبر بان الدولار لازال امن ولا
علاقه له لا يمكن ان يتاثر بازمه كهذه
داخل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه صحيح
الى الان لن يتاثر لان معظم الديون حول
العالم مرتبطه بالدولار
وطالما شفنا ان معظم الديون حول العالم
بطروحه بالدولار لابد ان نرى ان العمله
الاساسيه ستكون دولار لان دائما سداد ديون
لابد ان تصير او يعني تكون في الدولار
فهذا الربط مع الديون هو اللي معطي
الدولار قوته دكتور محمد البعض يقول بانه
تم النجاح في احتواء هذه الازمه هل تعتقد
بانه تم احتواءها فعلا او يجب ان ننتظر
كيف سيكون
المستقبل خاصه في ساعات القادمه او الايام
القليله القادمه
انا اعتقد انه التدخل السريع من البنوك
المركزيه كان جدا ممتاز مقارنه يعني بما
حدث في الازمه الماليه في عام 2008 لكن
هذا لا يعني احتواء الازمه بشكل كامل احنا
بنقول نحتاج فعلا انه احنا بنراقب ولازلنا
في حاله عدم التاكد القطاع المصرفي قطاع
في غايه الاهميه وخليني اكون اكثر ربطا
بما حدث في هذه المصارف يمكن المصارف
الموجوده في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كان السبب الرئيسي انا اعتقد يعني يعني
عاملين اساسيين العامل الاول انه ارتفاع
نسب الفائده اللي ما في شك انها اثرت على
نشاطات هذه البنوك لانه هذه البنوك بتعمل
في نشاط معين الا وهو نشاط يعني خليني
اقول
اقراض الشركات التقنيه بالتحديد واللي
واجهت مشكله كبيره مع ارتفاع الفائده
الجانب الاخر انه ايضا استثمارات هذه
البنوك يعني انا اعتقد انه هذا ايضا من
الخطا الاداري اللي كان يقول اداره المصرف
بشكل كامل
لو كانت الاستثمارات يعني بتمثل اغلب
الاستثمارات حوالي 91 مليار في اذونات
الخزانه سندات اذونات الخزانه وقروض الرهن
العقاري وما في شك انه هذه تاثرت بشكل
كبير مع ارتفاع الفائده فبالتالي انعكست
سلبا على نتائج هذه البنوك واللي شاهدنا
الانهيارات اللي حصلت لكن ما حدث في
الحقيقه كريدي سويس امر مختلف تماما اللي
حصل ان هناك خسائر قدرت بحوالي 7.9 مليار
في العام 22 بالاضافه الى فقد الثقه وفقد
الثقه طبعا نتيجه يعني بعض الامور او
الفساد الاداري اللي يعني حصل في في البنك
وهذا ما في شك ادى الى انه المودعين
يسحبوا يعني ودائعهم وحصل يعني احتواء
الازمه من خلال استحواذ بنك يو بي سي
عليها نعم دكتور طارق البعض يقارب بين ما
يحدث اليوم ما حدث في 2008
ولفتته موضوع
المده الزمنيه بمعنى ان ما حدث في 2008
كان على مده زمنيه طويله في حين ان سرعه
ما حدث اليوم من تاثيرات على البنوك على
المصارف وعلى الاسهم كذلك التي تم
احتوائها بشكل بشكل ما سرعه هذا الموضوع
لفت البعض ما تفسيره
انا ارى ان بلا شك يعني الموضوع مشابه
واعطيكم المثال يعني احنا نتوقع ان الازمه
الماليه في 2008 بدات مع انهيار بنك اليمن
وهذا كلام غلط يعني الازمه بدات مع انهيار
بنك
في شهر ثلاثه
الرقابيه وساعدوا جيبي مورجن في الاستحواذ
على بنك وشرى البنك بمقدار تقريبا دولارين
للسهم وقبل اشهر كان يتداول هذا السهم بما
حول 140 دولار فيعني هذه صوره مشابهه لما
حصل مع يو بي اس وكراد سويس وطبعا اهدات
الامور وشفنا مرور الصيف ومع مرور الزمن
الى ان اشتعلت الازمه مره اخرى مع انهيار
باكليمون فهل احنا نتابع نفس السيناري
ونفس المرحله هذه عليها علامه استفهام
دكتور محمد اخطب معك بما يجب ان يكون
كنصيحه كذلك للمشاهدين هل تعتقد في مثل
هكذا مراحل ليست ازمه حضرتك قلت بانها
بدايه تشكل ازمه هل يجب ان
نستثمر السيوله في شيء اخر في العقارات
مثلا ان نقسمها على اكثر من بنك او ان
نحتفظ بها كما هي ونتابع الموضوع
طب اذا سمحتي لي انا خليني يعني اركز اجل
في عمليه الاستثمار في يعني في المنطقه
عندنا خصوصا في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
او في المنطقه العربيه انا اعتقد انه
المنطقه العربيه ودول مجلس التعاون
والمستثمرين هنا يعني ما في اثر اليوم
كبير عليهم لانه الانهيارات اللي حصلت
اليوم في البنوك الموجوده في الولايات
المتحده او حتى في ما في عندنا نسبه كبيره
جدا من الاستثمارات العربيه باستثناء
استثمار البنك الاهلي اللي يعادل حوالي
9.8% في كريدي فبالتالي اذا كان من نصيحه
نستطيع تقديمها للمستثمر اللي هو راغب
اليوم انه يدخل حقيقه بنقول له
الهدوء وعدم الاستعجال الحقيقه في وضع
استثمارات في الوقت الحالي لانه اليوم
اللي عنده كاشا الحقيقه انا اعتقد ان هو
ينتظر فرص مستقبليه افضل من ان هو يجازف
بالدخول في استثمار شكرا على كل ما تفضلتم
به من معلومات من لندن الدكتور طارق رفاعي
رئيس تنفيذي لمركز كورونا من الرياض
الدكتور محمد كينيا والاستثمار في جامعه
الامام شكرا لكمما السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]